the big bet here the big wager is
paulie's got Golden State I don't know
if John Canzano knows this the great
columnist for The Oregonian and he joins
us now
John do you realize that Paulie is
taking Golden State and wants to bet you
a thousand dollars on who wins the
series kind of odds is he gonna give me
no no he said you've already picked
Portland to win therefore you don't
really know Portland in six minutes
why does everybody want to pick on the
small market I hope Portland wins by the
way I heard you nicknamed CJ McCollum
and Damian Lillard we were talking about
this yesterday on my show yeah what Dan
why I said how come splash brothers for
Klay and Steph and and the Portland guys
don't have a nickname and everybody said
Dan Patrick already named them the rain
brothers yeah the rain bros that right
yeah yeah I'm a I made shirts three or
four years ago and it's it's got a
rainbow but you know shooting a jumper
with the the rain bros i like that but
is it is it a ripoff of the splash
brothers come on I like it I think it's
I think it's cooler than splash brothers
because that's a that's a takeoff of the
bash brother so okay then they ripped
off the bash brothers
rain rain roses Seaton's going back to
see if he can fall I mean let's pick up
you know but let's bring back the
rainbow is John I like it all right I
like it we'll go with it cuz I said
yesterday I said how come they don't
have a nickname everything going to
listen to Dan Patrick I said I listen to
him every day but I guess I missed it
alright summarise your column here of
why Portland is going to win in six John
well look I don't like Golden State's
bench and I and I picked against the
Blazers in the opening round I said
there's no way they're getting by the
Thunder they get by the Thunder they
just have found a way at every juncture
of this season the and I don't know
who's gonna step up
it could be Jake layman beating the
Warriors who knows but it has been
Rodney hood it has been enes kanter
it has been CJ McCollum we all know what
Damian Lillard can do I feel like the
Blazers are going to steal one of these
first two games I think they're going to
win their two home games I think Golden
State's going to be facing a 3-1 deficit
going back facing elimination so I think
Golden State's in a little trouble here
and you did point out the age difference
at about three years average age for
Golden State against Portland
you also have depth with Portland and
you know you had that survival mentality
but then I also go back to what I don't
know what Golden State is right now
without Durant when Durant comes back
the fact they may play the first two
games without him you know does that
bode well better for Portland that these
first two games without Durant it feels
that way but you know this is the same
team that went into Houston and beat
Houston in a you know must-win situation
for him so what do you expect from
Golden State well the Warriors are great
we all know that but I felt like in the
opening round against the Clippers we
all saw they were they were
disinterested
they were looking to the Houston Rockets
and saying that's the Western Conference
Finals so I think people in Portland are
sort of hoping that they feel like they
already won the Western Conference
Finals and that this is another early
round matchup for them I feel like if
Portland can can Portland has to win one
of these four games to win this series
they have to I think I have to win
tonight I mean I think that's that is
the game for them because I think the
Warriors we've all seen it they get a
little bored they're a little
disinterested they're that good but I
think if the Blazers are going to get
when they get one tonight and they do
what they need to do in Golden State and
then they come back home they're they're
terrific at home I think that you know
the season series supports that they
split the season series but you know at
some point Durant comes back and we've
all seen this whether it's DeMarcus
Cousins or Durant when a guy comes back
into the lineup we watch teams struggle
to sort of adjust share the ball I
thought the lawyers look better without
Durant and they did with him but so I'm
sort of counting on that to be a factor
and this Blazers team has just been
counted out at every juncture and if you
go by Oracle Arena you drive by it what
do you see out in front of the arena you
see this giant billboard with Damian
Lillard picture on it and and you know
that's he used to walk he could walk to
to that Coliseum from his neighborhood
I feel like this series has got a lot of
personal appeal to Lillard the Blazers
are playing with a chip on her shoulder
they're dangerous then
I think it's gonna be really compelling
basketball Paulie is gonna change the
bet well I'm just worried because you
know working in the media I don't want
John to get in trouble for betting
actual cash how about I pick a
restaurant portal and a real nice one
Portland wins you could take the family
out there on me and vice versa like that
let's do it how about the there's a
restaurant in Portland called a couple
people on internet said screen-door
supposed to be awesome let's practice it
let's do Swank
Swank is a downtown restaurant it's got
a moonshine and whiskey bar across the
way called swine
you could go to Swank or swine you pick
okay Wow okay and then but you got to
find a restaurant for John to pick up
the tab for you appalling
yeah and I'm taking you guys John so
it's gonna be pricey yeah you know I do
love this this is the one thing I love
about this John is it allows the nation
to see Portland as a fan base and it
allows them to see that backcourt that
is overshadowed and it's a chance for a
coming-out party it's it's weird damian
lillard
became an overnight sensation after what
seven or eight years in the league with
that shot that he hit against OKC and CJ
McCollum hopefully gets that same
coming-out party so from that standpoint
I I'm glad Portland's here
I hope they win and I you know I hope
that they get some notoriety even Terry
Stotts yep you know with the job that
he's done there in Portland in Dan let
me tell you I mean you've done a great
job recognizing that and I think you're
one of the few national voices that that
has had Willard and Stotts on your show
and talked about them but how would this
be great for the league or bad for the
league for the lawyers to get knocked
out by amid you know a small market team
at this juncture of the playoffs is this
good is this good if it's milwaukee and
portland or is it bad i as a basketball
fan I think it's great but I'm not a TV
executive and I don't care to think that
way I just look at it and say what would
be fun what would I don't want I don't
want something predictable John and I
think that's the problem we've had with
Golden State is it felt predictable
there for the regular season didn't mean
anything you know people didn't have
Portland making the playoffs this year
believe it or not
and that's what I found amazing and you
know the fact that they've gotten this
far and if they would happen to get into
the finals I think it would be great I
really do because it would be
unpredictable and that's what's made
this run so good for the Blazers that we
just have never known on a day-to-day
basis who's gonna step up and it could
be Seth Curry in the face of his brother
it could be Zach Collins who had his
coming out party sorted in the last
series and looks like a player that the
Warriors are going to have to account
for
we just haven't known in Lillard scoring
13 points and that's game 7 I thought he
played one of his better games and I've
been hard on this franchise they lost 10
straight playoff games entering this
season I thought they were going nowhere
I was saying break up the backcourt and
now I'm looking at him going you know
this makes sense yeah I thought that
that if they bowed out against OKC that
then maybe there was changes happening
in Portland but you know what you got a
great backcourt there and hopefully
they're able to play up to that
potential and you know go toe to toe
with that backcourt with Golden State
John it's great to talk to you our best
to the great city of Portland and we
appreciate your time thanks Dan that's
John Canzano so Pauli has the bat it's
dinner that's fine
swank and swine that sounds good yeah
but we don't get to go to Portland for
the swank and swine who says well I did
I mean I'd love to go back to Portland
what if Portland makes the NBA Finals
mmm what do you smell I smell no no you
to smell it we haven't been to Portland
in like 10 years I know it's my first
Bloody Mary I ever had it was a hammer
to his like yeah I was with Seton we
came back from the show that day and I
have no idea why I just said how about a
Bloody Mary I think it was like 9:20 in
the morning I said how about a Bloody
Mary he goes yeah I'm up for it
sat down and the Bloody Mary it was
pretty pretty big glass
Bloody Mary there ham tasty too afraid I
don't know what I had for breakfast but
I had a Bloody Mary I know that nice nap
right after yes I did yeah I loved they
have all the food carts of food trucks
down downtown like a city block full of
great food trucks yeah now we really
loved Portland
love Portland I could have stayed there
yep just stay there for a little while
yeah very pretty for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]